Speaker 1: Well, Donald Trump's own special
master is kind of telling him to cut the crap.
This is not going particularly well for the
failed former president so far. And it's super
interesting because this is exactly what Donald
Trump wanted. So let me reset the story. So we
all get on the same page. One of the things that
really the main thing that Donald Trump and his
lawyers did to try to slow down this investigation
by the FBI that happened subsequent to the search
warrant being executed at Mar a Lago where all of
these documents were taken. What Donald Trump did
is demand the appointment of a special master.
Special master would get to take control of
the documents seized by the FBI and review them
and say, do some of these have private medical
information? Are some of these privileged in
some way and slow down the FBI's ability to use
those documents in their investigation? Trump
handpicked a special master, and the special
master is doing Donald Trump no favors. And it's
actually a delight. You see, this is from Talking
Points Memo. U.S. District Judge Raymond Dearie
for the Eastern District of New York injected
some normalcy into Trump's civil case against the
Justice Department. Deary chastised attorneys for
Trump during the hearing for refusing to produce
any evidence that the record seized by the FBI
from Mar a Lago in August had actually been
declassified. Jim Trusty, a Trump attorney, told
Diary he wanted to examine the records taken by
the government as he decided whether to make that
assertion. And Dearie said, You can't have your
cake and eat it too. Deary exhibited skepticism
of the Trump team's classification arguments
elsewhere in the hearing, he kept asking Trump's
team versions of the same question If I'm going to
verify the classification, what am I looking for?
This is really, really interesting. Here
is a report from CNN about what went down.
Speaker 2: Judge jury posed the
question to Trump's team or he said to
them, you know, if he gets a prima facie
case that the documents are classified perhaps by
the markings, and if Trump's teams don't tell him
that these documents were declassified, he said he
essentially would as far as he as he is concerned,
he would go with the prima facie case and that
would be the end of it. Right. So really putting
the issue to Trump's lawyers, he noted that the
burden was on them in this case for them to decide
if they were going to put forward any position
that any of these documents had been declassified.
And as we've been talking, that is something
that the former president has said publicly on
his social media feed. But it is not an argument
that his attorneys have made yet in this case.
Speaker 1: This is the best and I've talked to
you about this before. One of the I did a clip
must have been about two weeks ago where I
said, are Trump's lawyers going to try these
arguments in court? And one of the arguments
was about the classification status of some of
the seized documents and Trump's alleged broad
blanket abracadabra declassification. And one
of the things we've learned is that a lot of
the things you say in the media don't hold up
in court. We saw this after the 2020 election in
the 60 plus cases that were brought to different
courts, in this particular case, in social
media and elsewhere, the argument has been
made. Trump declassified everything, and what
the Special Master is saying is, if you hand me
a document and it says classified and you don't
assert and prove that Trump declassified it,
that's it. It's a classified document, and
that's all there is to it. And this is not
what the Trump team was hoping for. Really
funny, as Trump's legal team is showing up
to court. There's someone holding a nuclear secret
sign in the background and people yelling, Indict
Trump and all sorts of other hilarious things.
Speaker 2: In a big way and fly on the wall for
the worst lawyers in America.
Speaker 1:
All right. So a brief moment
of excitement there outside
the courthouse. I've said it before.
Try it in court. Try it under oath.
And then they don't. So we're going to be
following this very closely. But early on,
this entire special master thing not
going particularly well for Donald Trump.